The joe rogan experience watching
and I'm gonna say this in.
Then the idea's going to be there.
All the business guys
take off their jackets.
You know they have the shirt and ties
and they throw him over the back of their
chairs.
I'm a new invent suit.
Jackets that aren't real ones.
They just cover the back of your chair.
So you see that as a piece of year suit,
but you don't have to wear the jacket.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
You got to tackle brilliant,
brilliant idea.
You're talking about signage.
Jackets are never a good idea.
John,
half run.
They're going to go in the back
conference room yourself too long.
Virtual fist pump you jackets that
are going to go on the back of,
because here's the thing,
when you do those,
you don't have to wear dress
pants because they can't it.
They're like newscasters.
So the new look,
you can go board shorts,
flip flops,
maybe a nice shirt with a tie,
fake jacket cover over the thing.
You look like you're wearing a suit
and you've got probably talent,
brain dog dies or a NASA.
In the beginning of the show brain doctor,
you need to go see one
telling you you're going to,
you're going to see it.
You're all gonna throw it out there.
John Heffron I'd be willing to
bet you an insane amount of money.
That fake jackets that you put on the
back of your study will exempt to catch on
because he will exist.
Cause I'll create them.
You will.
They will exist and they will be a money
pit of disastrous proportions for I
need a sanction as your direct message.
Me,
I need a seamstress.
What is it like dealing with those people
in that world and doing like squeaky
clean comedy only and not being able to
take any chances up there or go into any
weird directions.
What does that like?
I've always done that type of comedy so
it's not weird you your Carmoney has,
I mean I'm,
I'm an adult but I'm not,
you know,
I don't get ever super grand.
I'm,
I believe you can turn a clean bit dirty,
just buy things then vice versa.
But yet you are one of the most perverted
people I've ever met my wife up with
that.
Plus I think it's weird when you
have jobs that then affect you.
Like when I used to do
morning radio with Bonaduce,
we are on a soccer mom station.
You guys run a soccer mom station.
We were like,
well Danny tried to get in a
fight at a matchbox 20 concert.
So that shows you what kind of enhancing,
try match.
But in a fight and a matchbox,
he,
it was a great,
he took off his shirt and was
going to fight the entire row.
J J at Pine Knob.
Why would the shirt off?
Because he cleaned the bathroom.
I think this is back when Danny partied.
I think Danny met up with the
listener and the disappeared.
Oh,
whatever happened.
So he came back in an altered state?
No,
he was never that type of guy liquor.
I think we resigned and he's talking,
he's talking about this story.
So I'm not thinking of,
but it was that date rape drug.
What?
Everything he did GHB.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So yeah,
but,
but Danny scar tissue,
he did admit to all this stuff.
I don't know how that guy,
but so he did.
So then he came out crazy.
Did you say Danny is scar tissue?
His whole body is,
or there's no way you can be alive
with all the stuff that he's done.
Really?
There's no way you,
you have to be totally embalmed.
What did they do that with frogs?
The,
the body body's preserved.
Yeah.
Formaldehyde.
Yeah,
his,
that's his entire body.
Really?
Oh yeah.
He's a Zombie.
You can't,
he's not alive.
What's wrong with him?
He's just done so much stuff to his body.
What was it like working with that guy?
How long have you worked with them?
Different Kessel five years.
Five years on the radio.
Every morning I get up every
15 in the morning and Michigan,
which means that's when I
scraped off the ice on my thing.
Drove 45 minutes.
How many months a year is it snowing like
that and Michigan and started December
and go to like May.
June.
Yeah.
I mean it's,
so that's a long drive.
A June,
seven months.
April.
Yeah.
Half the half the year
after the cold and crappy.
Yeah.
Okay.
So cold and crappy.
You get up three 30 in the morning,
you're doing standup at night still.
Yeah,
round town.
Um,
but it was awesome cause
I would sell out stuff.
Right?
I mean there were some benefits.
I wasn't the course and that was 25,
26.
Why would you ever want to sleep
then you go radio bar appearances,
you know,
like I was that guy movie premieres,
but he got paid a lot of money.
How crazy was daddy?
Ah,
beyond crazy?
Because the thing with Danny as you never
knew which guy you were going to get.
You can have a guy that you work
with that's a consistent ass,
but at least then you know how to tip toe.
Other Times,
Dan,
you'll be the coolest human
being you've ever met.
And then you come in the
next day and you'd go,
he's going to literally slit my throat.
The only advantage,
I mean did it.
Now we're,
we're really good friends and at first he,
he hated me.
He wanted to hate you.
Um,
well,
I never did radio before I met him.
I was just a comic round town and I
didn't know how to talk to that person.
It's try having a conversation with him.
It's tough.
So imagine being a 22 year old kid,
not,
you know,
David [inaudible].
And I was like,
yeah,
but one time I,
you know,
I just didn't have my rhythm.
I just didn't know.
So he hated you because,
oh,
hated me.
Hated working with you.
Hated just,
yeah.
Yeah.
They didn't want to work with you.
He didn't want to know why did we fired?
I just moved back from Los Angeles.
So I moved to from Detroit to Los Angeles
and then got that job and move back to
Detroit and then got fired
maybe three or four weeks later.
And then did he get you fired?
Yeah,
he,
he got me fired and then we
went to Chicago together.
It was odd for some weird thing.
And then we,
he didn't suddenly liked me and then,
then I was on the shelf.
You know what,
what are you talking about?
We did a radio show
together for some reason.
Why we were doing it in Chicago.
Something clicked where he's like,
oh,
I get you now have friend.
Okay,
you're in.
Then it was so,
I'm so confused.
Okay.
You started off together in Michigan.
You did a radio show.
He got you fired me fired condo.
They were going to give me,
you know,
did you go to Chicago?
What does the Chicago trip boat?
I got fired on a Friday and we were going
to go to Chicago on Monday to do a hid
this loop.
The loop in Chicago.
Okay,
so we doing it as a permanent
gig or the Andes thing was a,
I can't believe they did that.
You know,
why don't you come to Chicago?
We'll do the show Monday so puts you up.
I didn't know.
Still confuses.
He's still doing a show in
Michigan and he does a shelter.
Yes.
He would do morning shows in
Detroit afternoon in Chicago,
so he would get on a southwest flight.
Wait a minute.
He did a show every day in two markets.
Yes.
Oh my God.
Get on a southwest flight and
fly from Detroit to Chicago.
Do the thing and then
get on another flight,
fly back.
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
Every day.
He did that for a couple months and then,
you know,
then he figured out technology but keep,
you know where they can ISD and
at where he could do it in thing.
But he was doing that every day is insane.
Yeah.
How long is the flight in?
Minutes?
20 minutes.
40 F yeah.
So it's going to Vegas like flying to
Vegas and he would do it every day back
and forth and then do his radio show.
Holy Shit in Chicago.
Yeah.
You gotta give the Guy Credit for
that and I wonder why he was on drugs.
So he got,
had to be on drugs to do that.
So I was fired,
but he didn't tell me that it was,
he was like,
I can't believe they did that.
I,
that's like,
so he didn't,
I didn't know you that he got fired.
So it goes,
why don't you just come
to Chicago this weekend?
We'll,
we'll party.
That just sucks.
Have friend.
But you know,
well,
so he's kind of like,
probably felt guilty.
I'll let your party in Chicago with
me and then you're gone for a light.
Okay.
Did the show with them on that Monday.
And he's like,
you know what,
I'm going to make a call like we had,
cause he never listened to me.
Well,
you know what I mean?
Like what's the problem on the show
if you would just listen to me.
He knows.
So anyway,
long story short,
I came back and you're like,
Eh,
you know,
we won't fire you but we'll give you,
you got to take a pay cut.
Because I was making,
you know,
keep in mind,
I'm 23,
24 morning radio in
Detroit making $150,000.
Wow.
I mean,
that's like $1 million to a 23,
24 years.
Was this because why were
they giving you a pay cut?
What are they doing?
You know,
because I was,
I had no management or anything
and they're a huge corporation.
They're like,
you get the Gig in the first place.
Uh,
this huge radio guy,
Dick Curtin in Detroit,
was leaving the radio station and
he suggested to that management,
you need to bring this Heprin kid in.
Keep in mind,
I'm just starting college,
you know,
so then they go and you know,
Dick knows your most standup comedian.
Yeah.
And it was on a show and he was probably
the most famous radio guy in Detroit.
So they hired me just because
of that and put me with Danny.
But Danny,
how crazy.
[inaudible] he's the guy who,
and I've told him,
well anyway,
he's the one who got me into fighting.
Um,
he was really in the boxing and stuff.
So then what he did was he came to the
radio station and he had like headgear
cups,
a boxing gloves and says,
you know,
I'm friends with Jackie Callan,
we're going to go to her
place and we're going to,
I want you to learn to box so
I have somebody to spar with.
So he bought me all my appointments.
He bought me all my equipment,
got me crazy coaches and goes after it
and I'm going to take you out of box.
So I have somebody to,
and we're going to spar everyday from,
from 12 to 12 to three.
That's ridiculous.
So long time to get good at boxing kid,
just start sparring.
Someone had been doing it forever.
Yeah.
So I,
so I got the stuff and then um,
then me and Danny fought and I would
never been more afraid of my entire life.
Like the,
there's a thing about fighting.
You can be a really good,
you go to class,
you want to think,
but you have to have that thing in you
that makes you want to kill people,
which I've never had.
I enjoy fighting and I
learned learning stuff,
but I don't have that morale.
There's that thing.
Danny is a complete psycho.
He completely has that
thing and we'll kill you.
Then that's when that shortly after,
that's when he gave me a concussion.
Hit me right in the back of the head,
um,
to have people punching on you,
dude.
Yeah,
I know God.
That's right.
Danny Bonaduce though.
That's when we,
so he hit me in the back of the head.
I went home,
the girl I was dating at the time
comes to my apartment and goes,
why'd you buy a VCR on my kitchen
table from best buy out a VCR?
I'm like,
I didn't buy a VCR.
She's like,
yeah,
well,
who's his Atago?
I Dunno,
looked saw the credit card
receipt was my signature,
but this was weird.
This was in the nineties when
people bought DVD players.
So I actually went
backwards in technology.
Don't remember buying the VCR.
She took me to the hospital and then the
guy did the stand up on one foot thing
and I fell over and he's like,
what's the matter?
So then you know,
I had a really world duci knocked you
backwards and the technological progress
with with a punch knocked
you back to the visa.
And then after that he
reclaim your friends.
Why wasn't there any anyone around
the stop you from boxing him?
I had no guidance.
That's so sad.
I had no guy.
I wish I could have been your friends.
I know.
No,
I had no guys don't do a chart.
We need you here on earth.
We need you for your brain.
We need you to be funny.
We can't have,
but after that Denny,
you know like me and stuff like that.
So let him punch you and fire you.
And he's the best guy ever.
Yeah.
You just gotta go with a bit bit of a
gauntlet and then he got a show in Philly
or something.
Yeah,
he's married.
He's about to get married again.
Who's he married?
Uh,
I don't know.
How do you know this?
I know somebody that knows somebody
who knows somebody who's marrying him.
Yeah.
Really?
Oh,
oh.
Tell me more.
Very interesting.
Yeah.
He was dominating.
Interesting guy.
Yeah.
To get a fight out of matchbox 20 concept,
you really having to work.
Cause that crowd is not
necessarily violent.
Oz Fest.
Yeah.
Matchbox Fox 20 it's guys
being forced to take the girls.
You never know,
man.
Some emo get really pissed when they
see the chick with another dude and they
realize,
oh they're crying isn't worth right.
[inaudible]
you're a fucking human being.